RILEY SHEAHAN,
CIRCLE ALL THE
THEY'VE WON FOUR IN A ROW, FOUR
OF THEIR LAST FIVE AND THENT.
DUNN GETS TO IT, HE'LL WRAP IT
IN THE DARK AGES.
NOWKS ARE A GREAT STORY.
EBER AND
BACK.
PICKED OFF BY THE HAWKS. IN.
NOW BACK OF THE GOAL, CARSON HA
BLACKHAWKS TAG OUT, EBERLE GETS
IT,  WIDE.
OUT IN FRONT.
DOMINIK KUBALIK GOES TOPNO MIST
SHOT, DOESN'T TRY
OWN GOALS. KANE, GRUBAUER SAYS
NO, BUT CHANCE GRUBAUER IS ABLE
TO KNOCK ITCORNER, DE
HAAN MOVES IT FOR THE REBOUND,
CHANGES THE ANGLE, WASN'T ABLE
TO GET HIS STICK OUT LIKE TOEWS.
MUZZLED BYAPPLETON.
JARNKROK, WIDE, GETTING TO IT
McCANN, GIORDANO FROM THE LINE.
TOP OF THE  THERE.
RIGHT THERE, SAVES LIKE THAT IS
WHY HE HAS HAD SUCH A McCANN
IN THE RING, WILL STRETCH IT OUT
TO THE LINE, ALL THE WAY
DeBRINCAT, WENNBERG GAVE IT
GETS IT FROM  CENTER
ZONE TO THE OUTSIDE, HE'LL GET
IT FROMRE ABLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGF
ONE OF CHICAGO'S
OUT RECORDS, NEUTRAL ICE.
HERE COMES
TEN SESE WIDOW WITH DOHEY, WHAT
DONSKOI HAS SCORED, THE KRAKEN
WINN